the moments of truth for Bragdon
aggravations will be the october
european council the migration debate
showed that we may not agree on
everything but we agree on the main goal
which is stemming illegal migration to
Europe we decided to continue our focus
on what unites us and what have already
brought results our eu27 working lunch
today we had a good discussion on brexit
which once again reconfirmed our full
unity
first we reconfirmed that there will be
no withdrawal agreement without a solid
operational and legally binding Irish
backstop and we continue to fully
support initial Barnea in his efforts to
find such a model second we agreed to
have a joint political decoration that
provides as much clarity as possible on
the future relations everybody shares
the view that while there are positive
elements in the checkers proposal the
suggested framework for economic
cooperation will not work not least
because it risks undermining the single
market third we also discussed the
timetable for further negotiations in
October we expect maximum progress and
results in the bracket talks then we
will decide whether conditions are there
to call an extraordinary summit in
November to finalize and formalize the
deal
[Music]